dude couple weeks ago girl on the beach
i freaking she was leaving to go to her
car i
strategically left at the same time okay
am i
a stalker i don't think i am okay
it was daytime um it was hot
out i i if i stalked i would do it in a
colder climate
or time time time it you know
night time um but
i i started talking to her we had a
mutual friend
i got her ig i messaged her
she didn't message me back okay
so first of all kate why don't you
eat one of my nuts
and secondly i did what i could
i showed up you know and i was
and for like 40 minutes i was sitting
far away from her on the sand and i was
trying to think of a reason to go over
there and then i saw a bird over there
and i was gonna try to go and look at
this bird and like
but then i'm like what [ __ ] guy he's
like hey
look at this bird hey what are you doing
here you know like i just couldn't think
of a line to come off of the bird
hey you know oh man there's birds out
here
what do you what do you know anything
about them
you know i just couldn't think of
anywhere to go with it so that's where
i'm at